[Musica]
chiedete mai ai vostri figli se sono
felice a scuola
me lo chiedo spesso anch'io in tanti
anni di insegnamento ho visto la scuola
a perdere via via di vista le più le più
ovvie e consolidate conoscenze
pedagogiche fino ad arrivare al
paradosso di un'istruzione Povera
standardizzata burocratica e noiosa
anche se non ovunque per fortuna e a
intere classi di studenti passivi e
rassegnati un adolescente passivo e
spento È qualcosa di contraddittorio e
di spaventoso insieme non dovrebbe
essere un'esplosione di energia ed
entusiasmo che cosa manca perché questo
avvenga dovremmo rispondere a questa
domanda e ce ne sono altre Quale modello
educativo è adatto a riscattare questa
generazione di ragazzi quale adulto ci
immaginiamo come risultato dell'intero
percorso e in sostanza quale mondo
futuro vogliamo costruire
intanto chiariamo istruire ed educare
non sono la stessa cosa spesso la scuola
istruisce ma rinuncia a educare
l'istruzione e trasmissioni di
conoscenze ma l'educazione è molto di
più è una forma d'arte la più gravida di
futuro perché guarda avanti all'uomo
nuovo da plasmare e insieme è ricca del
sapere tramandato dalle generazioni
precedenti
i nostri ragazzi hanno bisogno non solo
di istruzione ma anche e soprattutto di
educazione perché hanno bisogno di
guardare al futuro
Provate a chiedere ai vostri figli come
si immaginano il loro futuro e chi
vogliono diventare Vi accorgerete che
molti di loro non vedono nulla davanti a
sé al massimo qualche incerta
prospettiva lavorativa il mondo in cui
viviamo è troppo liquido e
incomprensibile tocca a noi aiutarli a
pensare a un futuro vivibile e
accompagnarli nel complicato processo di
scoprire chi sono
il nostro ruolo è di essere un ponte
trapassato e futuro l'essenza
dell'educazione Infatti è conservare e
rinnovare insieme il suo fine è scoprire
e sviluppare potenzialità e Talenti dei
nostri ragazzi e farli crescere con cura
amorevole quando un ragazzo esprime la
sua essenza profonda nell'agire e nel
conoscere e ha pagato è in pace con se
stesso lo diceva anche Maria Montessori
il bambino è un embrione spirituale per
via delle infinite potenzialità che può
esprimere
Dobbiamo quindi chiederci Qual è l'uomo
che vogliamo per il XXI secolo
in pieno Umanesimo Giovanni Pico della
Mirandola Ci ha spiegato che cos'è
l'uomo l'uomo scrive È un grande
miracolo perché ha la capacità di
plasmare se stesso e di scegliere se
degenerare a livello dei brutti o
rigenerarsi nella sua natura Divina
Pico ci ha detto tutto ciò che ci serve
per la rinascita dell'umano e per la
fioritura del semi di lino che ci
portiamo dentro ognuno di noi deve
sviluppare la sua libertà interiore e la
sua creatività
perché non ci può essere un essere umano
senza libertà interiore senza creatività
Sarebbe uno schiavo senza coscienza e
non è certo Questo che noi vogliamo per
i nostri figli
Perciò ora è più che mai necessario dar
vita a un nuovo manesimo per rimettere
al centro e più autentici bisogni umani
e la dignità dell'uomo
è proprio di questo i nostri ragazzi
hanno bisogno di senso di relazione e di
direzione e questo è il nostro compito
di educatori
il mondo che verrà se vogliamo ancora un
mondo umano e non un incubo transumano
dovrà essere più consapevole e più
giusto dovrà essere fondato sulla
Cooperazione e sui valori spirituali non
certo sulla competizione o sull'avidità
e quando parlo di spiritualità non do al
termine alcuna connotazione religiosa o
New Age semplicemente lo spirito è ciò
che rende l'uomo umano e l'insieme delle
qualità più alte etica responsabilità
giustizia amore empatia bellezza
la spiritualità Infatti è
autotrascendenza ovvero capacità di
elevarsi al di sopra della propria mera
natura biologica e animale e di gettare
uno sguardo all'ol oltre all'oceano
sconfinato delle potenzialità di essere
e dei mondi possibili
senza questa qualità speciale non
avremmo la musica di Bach i dipinti
della Cappella Sistina di Michelangelo i
disegni di Leonardo I capolavori
dell'architettura gotica o la Divina
Commedia di Dante
la scuola del mondo che verrà dovrà
essere un luogo di gioia di libertà
consapevole di crescita integrale sul
piano fisico emotivo e intellettuale e
spirituale
una testa riempita di nozioni
frammentarie e come un cumulo di mattoni
senza calce e senza progetto non ci
serve Ci serve invece quello che diceva
Michel de Montaigne il Cinquecento
formare una testa ben fatta non ben
piena una persona Integra sveglia che
unisca armoniosamente corpo mente anima
e spirito che abbiamo amore per la
verità e per la bellezza
nella scuola del mondo che verrà si
imparerà in piccoli gruppi nella natura
i luoghi belli e luminosi L'esperienza
dell'imparare e del collaborare con gli
altri dovrà sempre essere associata
vissuti gratificanti e stimolanti a
queste condizioni la scuola sarà il
luogo più amato dai bambini e dei
ragazzi e saranno felici perché la loro
naturale curiosità e la loro motivazione
a mettersi alla prova saranno pienamente
soddisfatte D'altra parte non sarà più
necessaria la competizione perciò non ci
saranno nemmeno i voti
ma ciascuno riceverà in costante rimando
sui propri progressi
la tecnologia digitale che li ha resi
dipendenti e depotenziati avrà uno
spazio minimo almeno fino
all'adolescenza per dare il tempo al
cervello di formare le vie neurali
necessarie al pensiero complesso
per questo serve usare le mani e fare
esperienza si impara facendo infatti e
anche sbagliando
bisognerà riscoprire la felicità
dell'errore che quando ha colto e
analizzato
stimola l'onestà intellettuale e la
creatività
ci chiediamo mai quali siano i bisogni
fondamentali dei bambini e dei ragazzi
solo riconoscendoli possiamo dar vita a
una scuola su misura per loro
movimento all'aperto gioco natura
relazione amicizia fiducia manualità
empatia bellezza e soprattutto senso
molti ragazzi sono annoiati a scuola
perché non riescono a dare un senso a
ciò che studiano e cioè a rispondere
alla domanda a che scopo lo faccio
è difficile essere felici quando non si
riesce a dare un senso alla propria vita
e al proprio agire Per questo ci servono
insegnanti formati e selezionati con
molta cura dotati di talento pedagogico
di competenza comunicativa studiosi
appassionati delle loro materie persone
capaci di relazioni autentiche e oneste
ed entusiasti di stimolare i loro
allievi al limite delle loro possibilità
niente è più efficace di un insegnante
che ama ciò che insegna e che sollecita
a farsi domande come scriveva François
il bambino non è un vaso da riempire ma
un fuoco d'accendere tutti Noi
ricordiamo con nostalgia quegli
insegnanti che hanno saputo accendere in
noi la fiamma del desiderio di
conoscenza
per questo motivo Due anni fa ho deciso
di dar vita ad una comunità educativa
ispirata al modello del Giardino
filosofico di Epicuro ho radunato un
gruppo di adolescenti dai 16 ai 20 anni
e con loro e con alcuni colleghi ho
fatto l'esperienza di una serie di
seminari residenziali di alcuni giorni
nel verde
abbiamo condiviso i pasti le passeggiate
le meditazioni i laboratori di teatro di
arte di musica di Aikido e tanto
tantissimo sapere dagli ambiti più
disparati storia letteratura fisica
quantistica economia filosofia scienze
psicologia
mass media comunicazione
abbiamo parlato della morte e della
bellezza della mente e della coscienza
della libertà e del senso della vita
erano tristi ed emotivati All'inizio li
ho visti via via ritrovare la gioia la
vita e il desiderio di conoscere
ne ho concluso che per la nuova
educazione integrale e fondata sui
valori spirituali perenni ci servono la
conoscenza di sé la trasversalità il
pensiero critico
l'integrità e la creatività
la conoscere se stessi è fondamentale
per far brillare la propria luce
interiore e per ricordarsi che si è
veramente
un'essenza Divina ci ha detto Pico vuol
dire Inoltre soprattutto conoscere a
fondo la propria parte in ombra vuol
dire anche comprendere le trappole della
mente e sviluppare la coscienza per
questa scuola si imparerà la mindfulness
la presenza a se stessi alle proprie
sensazioni fisiche alle emozioni e i
pensieri si imparerà per esempio che la
consapevolezza del respiro può aiutare a
gestire l'ansia o che si può riuscire a
osservare i propri pensieri con distacco
dobbiamo abituare i ragazzi ad avere una
mente aperta e sgombra da pregiudizi per
questo occorre superare le barriere
stagni delle discipline e sviluppare la
trasversalità
l'eccesso di specializzazione ci fa
guardare al mondo dal buco della
serratura ma in un mondo così complesso
ci servono strumenti per decifrare la
complessità
collegando fra loro ambiti diversi del
sapere e dando vita a intuizioni e
sintesi originari come l'uomo universale
del Rinascimento l'allievo del futuro
dovrà abbracciare vasti Orizzonti
non c'è senso a scuola senza pensiero
critico pensare con la propria testa
permette di evitare false di riconoscere
falsità inganni e di difendere la
propria libertà
Ma come si può insegnare il pensiero
critico a scuola per esempio imparando a
farsi domande e a non dare niente per
scontato invece di ripetere passivamente
un sapere pre digerito
oppure a riconoscendo le manipolazioni
storiche logiche linguistiche
statistiche che distorcono la realtà per
questo ci servono la storia la logica la
lingua la matematica
li ho visti gli studenti dopo questo
tipo di lavoro diventano svegli e pronti
a mettere in discussione tutto ciò che
sentono anche da me
non se ne parla mai ma non ci può essere
educazione senza integrità
l'integrità ha a che fare con il senso
di avere dei Sani confini personali e di
farli rispettare Dobbiamo insegnare ai
ragazzi a volersi bene a essere empatici
con se stessi a prendersi cura di sé con
responsabilità solo così lo faranno
anche con gli altri e noi possiamo
essere soddisfatti quando imparano la
meravigliosa capacità di dire di no a
ciò che è dannoso per sé o per gli altri
la creatività e la caratteristica più
essenziale dell'essere umano
ed è la più necessaria nella scuola del
futuro
creatività e capacità di plasmare se
stessi e di trasformare il mondo in modo
imprevedibile perciò nella scuola del
mondo che verrà avranno un posto
centrale le discipline Creative arte
musica danza poesia teatro ma la
creatività riguarda qualunque attività
intellettuale per esempio la matematica
la filosofia l'educazione perfino
l'agire Quotidiano
creatività non è assenza di regole ma
apertura mentale ricchezza ideativa
audacia e anche disciplina interiore e
massima concentrazione
per valorizzare al massimo la creatività
negli studenti Però anche gli insegnanti
dovranno essere creativi e questo
significa liberarsi dall'abitudine E dai
pregiudizi
non c'è creatività senza bellezza la
bellezza e la via d'accesso ai mondi
spirituali perciò bisogna educare a
riconoscere e a creare il bello senza la
sensibilità al bello l'essere umano si
svilisce
uno dei momenti più indimenticabili che
ho vissuto con i miei ragazzi e dei
residenziali è stato vederli
completamente assorti e rapiti
nell'ascolto della lettura teatrale del
discorso di diotima sulla bellezza nel
Simposio di Platone seduti in cerchio in
mezzo al bosco
la scuola che verrà dovrà essere una
scuola viva una vera scuola di vita
Perciò richiederà il massimo impegno non
solo degli insegnanti ma anche dei
genitori noi adulti dovremmo imparare a
esprimere al meglio le nostre qualità
spirituali perché tutti noi per i nostri
ragazzi siamo un modello da imitare si
può insegnare Infatti solo solo ciò che
si è perciò dovremmo essere autorevoli
saper ascoltare saper dialogare saper
accogliere un adulta autorevole usa la
forza in modo protettivo
maicoercitivo e da poche regole ma
chiare e condivise soprattutto sa essere
autentico
la ricerca scientifica in psicologia ha
mostrato un interessante correlazione
fra autenticità e benessere psicologico
si sta bene con chi ci dà amore onestà e
rispetto e lo si riconosce subito
per gli uomini e le donne di domani
l'insegnante sarà la figura più preziosa
da prendere a modello per crescere
interiormente forti autonomi sensibili e
sveglie
bambini e ragazzi hanno bisogno di veri
maestri e la nostra responsabilità di
adulti verso le generazioni future sarà
testimoniare ai giovani Come si diventa
ciò che si è nel profondo di se stessi
solo così potremo ritrovare le qualità
più alte dell'essere umano e costruire
mondi sociali più Giusti consapevoli e
felici
tutto questo potrà sembrarvi
extraordinario in realtà sta già
avvenendo
[Musica]